hi i'm michelle klein member of the gsb
alumni association board and i'm pleased
to welcome you to this production
change organization yeah
change the world
[Music]
well thank you for the awesome
introduction i appreciate that i um
i was super nervous and then you all
started filing in and i was like these
are all my great friends that i made
over the last two years and so
i'm just so honored to be here and i am
so grateful that you
are entrusting me with this this last
lecture it's something that i take it
it's just an incredible honor it means
it means the world to me so so thank you
for that
um
i want to say congratulations to all of
you
not just on the last couple of years
but really on your whole lives
the 25 years or 30 years leading up to
getting to stanford and everything you
put into it
the incredible intensity
work the sacrifices you made the
decisions you made and
the grit that you showed to get here i
hope you feel like
you know you earned the seat that you're
sitting in and you belong here uh and
i just hope you'll over the next couple
of days appreciate really what you've
done because it's really impressive give
yourselves a big hand
[Applause]
the last lecture i took very seriously i
said this is my last lecture i'm ever
going to give what i'm going to say i'm
going to try to tie in things we talked
about in class things i talked about in
wellness and i'm going to talk about
even stuff we did during lunches and
stuff like that i'm going to do all that
in 25 minutes
see let's see how it goes
so uh
i turned 50 this year
and
as as many of you who know have had me
in class i'm a pretty reflective person
and i've thought about you know what's
what about what have i learned over that
time as drake said i've been on many
journeys had lots of
failures and some stuff go well and um
what i realized at the end of all that
is
that
life is really the most challenging
journey of all
that we're all going to have and that
all of you will have and then what i
realized over 50 years is it's really an
internal journey it's one that you're
gonna you're gonna really be wrestling
with yourself over that time
and there's a quote that i
love that summarizes this journey better
than anything i could come up with from
michelangelo
and michelangelo sculpted the david and
he painted the sistine chapel
and one of his early works was this
angel
people had never seen this
intricacy and detail in this angel
before
and they asked them you know how did you
sculpt this angel out of this block of
stone and michelangelo said famously
i saw the angel in the marble
and i carved until i set it
free the reason
that quote is so important and that it's
my favorite quote
is that we all of us
we're the angel in the marvel
and that we at our core are these
beautiful
infinite incredible
beings
we have power
beyond our wildest imagination
we're perfect just as we are
and
that the real journey is
to sculpt away
the stone that we're in case and and
most of the most constraining stone that
we have
we're actually
it's uh self-erected
it's this constraints we put on
ourselves
and that's things like
here's what my parents think i should do
here's what my roommate's doing you know
i compare myself to this person and i
compare myself unfavorably
you know i can't do this i don't know
how to do this
i'm not sure i'm going to make it
it might not work out i might fail and
i'm not ready i'm not enough
and really that's what's underneath a
lot of that is you know i'm not enough
so that's the stone that we kind of
place on ourselves
there's a subtle part of this quote
that i want to make sure come that i
make like not subtle which is
that michelangelo didn't sculpt the
angel or the david by
going out and finding a head
and gluing it on
and then finding wings
and then welding those on
he the angel was already perfect
and that really like if i had a gift i
could give to you
it would be for you to just give
yourself permission to be your true
selves over the course of your lives
that would be the gift i would give you
that's what i've learned over my 50
years
is that when you give yourself that gift
you tap into this energy source
and this joy and happiness and really
power that you
that you can't access any other way you
can't access it by trying to be someone
else
um so what i'm going to do today
is take you on a little bit of a journey
to hopefully uh help you un
you know unlock your potential kind of
carve away that marble over the over the
next 25 minutes or so
i'm gonna use use my own story to tell
you a little bit about this
so um
i
grew up in a small town in ohio
and actually my parents and my wife are
here who are from that same town
and uh
i i talk i talk about my wife all the
time in class and she's actually not
snuffle up against she's real and she's
here um
and uh anyway so i grew up in a small
town and i had this i had a lot of
marble
around me
i would have described myself as having
pretty average abilities athletic
abilities average
uh intellect really um
and i was i would say the town i was in
was average and that was my identity and
um
so i had these pretty pretty firm stone
walls
and then when i when i was about 13 like
a lot of us like i wanted to feel like
it mattered i want to feel significant
and so in in ohio one way to do that uh
was through athletics so i tried out for
basketball and i got cut and i tried out
for
um
football and i was too small
so we had we had wrestling in ohio that
was that was one of the sports we had
and wrestling you could be any weight
class and they didn't have cuts so i was
like all right great
my first three years seventh and eighth
in ninth grade um
really the only way to describe my
career would have been forgettable it
was just there was and that by the way
is a very optimistic description of of
those three years
so i got to
ninth grade that summer
and i said two words that i'd been
saying my whole life to that point
um i said not me
not now
you know i'm not the right person now's
not the right time
i go on walks with some of you and
you'll tell me about something you're
excited about and i'll hear you say
those words
not me not now you know i'm not i'm not
ready
that summer though two things happened
for me
uh one was
i bought a sony walkman
and this was the 1980s version of your
iphone
and this was magical just as magical as
the iphone was
and uh i i was at the library one time
checking out some music and there was
this program and it said think and grow
rich i was like
awesome
who doesn't want to think and grow rich
turns out that book wasn't at all about
thinking and growing rich it was about
conquering your inner self that's what
it's actually about it's a great book
napoleon hill but i became addicted to
these self-help
for lack of a better word uh audio tapes
listen to zig ziglar tony robbins uh
dale carnegie stephen covey so i had a
job over the summer that summer every
summer in ohio which was mowing lawns
i attached this walkman and i'd plow it
you know put in
tony robbins and then you know mowing
lawns is pretty straightforward you walk
in a line
in the sun and then when you're done you
get to the end of the road you turn
around and you walk back that's how
pretty much i just taught you how to mow
lawn and
and i did this for
six hours a weekend for my entire high
school and i brainwashed myself with
these tapes basically
and i was you know i my parents had just
gone through a divorce and and i wasn't
really part of a friend group and i you
know athletics wasn't really working out
for me so this became something for me
to grab on to i was really
impressionable and i grabbed onto these
with everything i had
so i'll summarize literally i added up
the hours one time and it's thousands of
hours i listened to i'm gonna summarize
it for you for in about two minutes
you're welcome
and the basic summary is that
about
99 of people never actually figure out
what they want
they have there's a lot of activity
they spend all this time they're running
around they're busy they're going all
these directions
but they actually never take the time to
figure out what is it that they want
and they said you will be the top one
percent if you could just figure out
what you want take that time
we're going to talk about that on today
the best exercise
that i know to figure out what you want
i've done with many of you in class but
i'm sorry i'm going to do it again
because this is my last
lecture is
imagine the following
imagine you rub a magic lamp
and a genie comes out
and the genie says to you
i can't give you any wish but what i can
give you is that whatever you throw
yourself into with your life whatever
you really commit yourself to
that that is going to work out amazingly
well
it's going to be way harder than you
think it's going to take longer than you
think you're going to have
some
face plants it's going to be tough and
when you fail you're going to think that
i've abandoned you but i haven't
but it's going to be the journey of a
lifetime you know what would you wish
for from that genie if you really had
that power if you really had that
blessing
that's my favorite prompt that i've i've
come up with and i've shared that
obviously with many of you
the second thing that happened
um
that summer was there was this movie
called vision quest how many of you seen
vision quest
like two of you
awesome actually and my wife too she's
i've made her see many times she raised
her hand
vision quest is so for those of you
don't know can't believe you haven't
seen it vision quest is a 1980s movie
it's kind of like rocky for wrestling
that's the best way to describe it
there's this wrestler named loud and
swain
and he decides he's going to cut down
two weight classes and he's going to
wrestle this defending state champion
brian shoot
and
and his buddy who's on kind of his
friend that goes on this journey with
him says how you know you're on a vision
quest this is a vision quest well this
is a b movie probably by any standard
except if you were
a 15 year old wannabe wrestler from
perrysburg which case it was my anthem
and i still to this day i've seen that
movie more than any other movie i've
ever seen i can say pretty much every
line in the movie
so anyway those two things conspired and
i go back to wrestling my
10th grade year
and i'm sitting in the i'm standing in
the wrestling room
and
i'm looking up at the wall we're having
a pizza party in the fall
and i'm looking up at the wall and
there's a list of all the starting
wrestlers and i'm not one of them
and
and and my buddy comes up and he puts
his arm around me and he says huh weaver
only place you can make that weight you
know make the starting lineup is at 125
pounds and he punches me in the gut like
literally and figuratively punches me in
the gut
so to give you an idea
um well anyway so i look at this i look
at this uh
and i decide that i'm and i and i have a
decision to make and i'm eating this
piece of pizza
and i throw the pizza in this trash and
i had this ceremonious moment where i
said all right i'm going to go on my own
vision quest i'm going to drop to 125
pounds make the starting lineup
now this story is not end the way that
vision quest does
i do make the weight but by the way just
give you a sense of 125 pounds i was at
the same height as i am now i weigh 185
right now
so when i decided to cut the weight i
was 150 and then i cut another 25 pounds
from that so it was to this day one of
the hardest things i've ever done
but
that moment when i threw the pizza pizza
in the trash would turn out to be the
turning point in my life
and the reason is that
i basically drew a line i didn't do this
figuratively but i did this kind of in
my head i drew this line here
and this line on this side of the line
is where i was and on the other side of
line are the things that i really
wanted the thing i wanted to be you know
the the goals that i had
and up till that point in my life
i'd always been tippitoe and putting my
toe in over on the other side of the
line
but i really never
believed it i never committed i never i
never stepped fully on the other side
and that was the first time in my life
where i knew when i threw that piece of
pizza away that this wasn't going to be
something i was going to do for a week
it wasn't something i was going to do
for a month this is something that i was
committed and i was going all in and i
did and mom can attest to that
so there are two things
my story today is i'm gonna share five
things with you five ways that you can
free yourself from the marble and i
uncovered two of them that i'll i'll
kind of highlight for you
in in that story
the first one is
that these walls that we have
that we have around us
and we we view them as stone and the
most dangerous when we don't even
realize that we have them and those are
the stories we tell ourselves the
assumptions we make the things that we
say we can and can't do
the most constraining walls that you
will have
are the ones that you have made in your
mind for yourself
those are the ones that will cause you
the most
you know problems
and
those walls are not actually made of
stone
but if you push them
they're malleable
and one way to push them hard is to
commit to step over and not look back
and then those walls will start to give
and they'll start to yield and you can
push and they'll move and so when i
pushed on this wall about first i had a
wall that was my athletic ability i have
a wall of intelligence my wall of who i
fit in my friends all that but i started
pushing on this athletic wall and it
moved and it gave and eventually i
cleared it out all together and as drake
said i became captain of a national
championship rowing team having never
rode before and i realized there was no
wall there at all
you know there's walls that was erecting
and the same was true with my view of my
identity for intelligence and many other
things is that they weren't walls at all
so my first takeaway is almost any wall
that you can imagine will yield
to you with time it will yield to you
when you're committed it will yield to
you at your best there's almost no wall
that won't yield
the second takeaway i have is has to do
with your identity
we all act
consistent with our identity
so we're gonna we're gonna behave today
the same based on how we perceive
ourselves what is our identity where
does so where's your identity come from
well your identity comes from your
subconscious mind
and your subconscious 95 of all the
things you think are in your
subconscious mind
and so your subconscious is really
powerful another thing i learned from
these these tapes
is your subconscious mind
and you've heard the expression we only
use a fraction of our minds how many of
you've heard that expression right we
only use a little bit so i would say it
differently i would say only a small
fraction of our mind is working for us
and the other 95 percent it's all over
the place and often more often than not
it's working against us
so our identity comes from when our
subconscious is picking up cues all the
time it says like you're not that good
at this you're not that good at that
you're not comparing well to this person
man i failed at this oh i'm not as good
as this i'm not you know that's our
identity is coming so really our
identity is coming from our past
what happened is
i started developing these genie goals
and having something having something i
actually wanted and and one of the
things these tapes would say is you know
visualize it write it down talk about it
all the time and in a very short period
of time my identity started becoming my
destination
it'll happen like that
so if you want to free yourself from the
marble
consider having your identity be where
you want to go not where you've been
it'll completely change the way you look
at the world
um i want to go back to the movie vision
quest for a second so vision quest is a
uh follows the arc of a of a very common
architecture of stories
uh joseph campbell
uh identified this arc
and when he called it the hero's journey
so the hero's journey goes something
like this
it says once upon a time once upon a
time there was a hero
and that hero felt something inside of
them they felt something that they had
this power that they were ready to give
to the world
and yet this hero lived in this ordinary
world and they'd experienced the power
at times but not fully they weren't
really 100 percent
like able to express this
and then the story goes on and says and
then one day
until one day something changed for that
hero they heard some call to adventure
some call to action
and the hero's reluctant at first
they're not sure if they should answer
this call
and i want to argue this is where many
of you are right now
you are make no mistake you know you are
the hero
you have this power inside of you that
you felt that you know is there
you've had this power that you've
expressed at times in your life that is
is incredible and you felt it
and i know from having from teaching you
having lunches coffees dinners drinks
i know that each of you also is hearing
a call
the call could be
that
you there's a problem that breaks your
heart that you want to be a part of the
solution the call could be that there's
something you want to introduce to the
world a product the technology something
like that
the call is it's it could be something
more subtle it could be it the call is
your call it's not it's not what i think
it's not what your neighbor thinks it's
not what your roommate thinks it's what
you think your call could be that you
want to be a teacher the call could be
you want to be an actor or a writer or
whatever it is
sometimes for some of you it's really
loud that call you know exactly what it
is and some for some of you it's a
whisper
but you got to listen to that call you
got to hear that
and many of you are reluctant right now
you're the you're in the reluctant hero
part of the story
from at least from spending time with
you
i was the reluctant hero too when i
graduated if you would ask me anytime in
the two years i was at stanford what are
you going to do i said i'm going to go
build a firm that's going to unleash
people and it's going to be built around
talent that's what i said i was going to
do and then when it came time to
graduate i listened to all my fears and
my doubts and my limiting beliefs
and i
kind of took
this and i had this decision to make
between these two jobs or doing what i
really wanted to do i made a decision
the way a lot of you make a decision
which is like this
i made it in my head you know and i got
and i said well here's a list of the
pros
and here's a list of the cons and here's
the good things here's the best i even
had a spreadsheet of expected value
and this is the way i know you make
decisions because i talk to you about it
and you all kind of go like this and
then
i asked 37 different people for advice
thinking the 37th was gonna have my
answer for me
i'm usually the 37th on your list too by
the way
um
so i made this decision and then of
course with all this stuff i i went to
the well-lit well-worn
path because that seemed more logical
and more
uh straightforward and that's where all
those
all that analysis led
me
i went to a firm and when i showed up
honestly a little bit of me died
and a little bit of me died that you
know each day i was there until
and i was so i kind of was like that
hero looking out the window and i'm kind
of like waiting for someone to come
rescue me
and take me on this journey
but after a while i stopped looking out
the window and i just became my
environment their values became my
values you know their goals became my
goals
once again in my life i had said not me
not now
not me not now
i had a
another catalyst
come in the form of
sort of a very tragic event which is a
close friend of mine uh he woke up like
all of us did today thinking he had his
whole life in front of him
and that was his last day
and
i uh
i realized that i don't know what i was
putting off you know i don't know when
the time was
if you know
if it's not now then when you know
when's it going to be and i told myself
at that time i was never going to say
the words not not me not now again and i
don't know that i have said it since
then
the third thing to think about in
unleashing yourself from the marble is
there there's another way to make a
decision
which is not in your head
but it's in your heart
and
there's a there's a quote which is you
can't solve the problems of the mind
with the mind
you can't solve you you can't you can't
solve your mind with your mind but you
can your answer is is most likely in
your heart so the way to make that
decision is to really silence your mind
and just think what's true for you
what's real give yourself
a space time
what would you know what meaning what
what's meaningful for you
what's the impact you want to have
what's
you know what would you do if you had if
you knew you weren't going to fail and
give yourself the space to think about
that
and my guess is you already know your
answer
you're just not giving yourself
permission
so the third thing is make your
decisions with your heart and not your
head
and
give yourself permission
nobody's coming to your rescue
i thought i'd talk quickly about the
journey itself
um some of you have started your journey
some of you are going to start later
some of your journeys are completely
different than my journey but i'll tell
you a little bit about my journey
because it's going to have some things
in common with yours i started my firm
and it took me a year to raise a fund
we raised way less than i thought it
took way longer than i thought
but we got going so we're in business
this was the first time i was going to
buy companies not using credit card debt
but i actually had some real money in
investors i was excited and then
promptly lost money on my first five of
my first eight deals
and lost money on the first my first
fund i had
probably 10 classmates invested in my
fund i lost them money i was embarrassed
i had at my fifth reunion i had a friend
put his arm around me and say
graham during the greatest wealth
creation of all time this is the dot-com
era you're buying stupid label printing
companies
i remember thinking
yeah that's pretty much accurate
not only am i buying stupid label
printing companies it's not really going
that well so it was uh it wasn't good
but we started clawing our way back
and then we you know got a little bit
better and then bam we got flattened by
the recession
didn't raise the fund for three years
and for the second time i drained my
savings keeping payroll going
uh
so this is my inspiring entrepreneurship
story
and but but the
but the point of the story is that
every journey
like using the hero journey analogy
think of like yoda in star wars or
princess bride the journey ends up in
the swamp you will end up in this swamp
at some point
and the swamp is where you're you're
mucking around in the mud
and you're not sure how to get out of
the swamp you don't know if you're gonna
get out of the swamp or when
and and and you feel like you have
failed you know this feels this this
swamp feels like failure is what it
feels like
but
i want to just talk about failure for
one second
i'm going to tell you that none of you
fear failure
and you're gonna be like no graham i i
pretty much fear failure
uh
but you don't
what you fear is underneath failure
which is you fear that you fear what
happens next
you fear that you can't handle failure
that whatever comes after that you're
not going to be able to handle it but
the failure but but then if you think
back to your lives
how many of you have had something go
really wrong that you would have
categorized as a failure
every single one of you and you know
what happened
you got up
you kept going you're here you're about
to graduate from stanford business
school no less
so
you you can handle failure every single
person can handle failure and that's
really what you fear
so in this swamp
this one quote is gonna is the thing
that kind of
helped me a lot is
this quote by vince lombardi who said
he was a coach of the green bay packers
and he said the green bay packers never
lost a football game but there were a
couple occasions where we ran out of
time i love that quote but the best
thing about the swamp is you're in
control of the most powerful part and
most the most powerful tool that you
need which is you have the clock
you know you're the one who gets to call
the game and you don't have to call it
until you're winning
so my fourth takeaway is
the journey you'll be on will go through
the swamp
and just recognize that that's normal
when you're in the swamp realize
everyone else has been in the swamp too
realize failure is not fatal
failure is not final
you can handle failure
and ultimately you control the clock
as uh winston churchill says if you're
going through hell keep going
so that's my my fourth takeaway so i'll
summarize my takeaways and then i'll
leave you with one final thought
first one is
the walls that are erected around you
the most constraining ones are the ones
you put on yourself
and
that those walls will move those walls
are not a stone at all they're very very
malleable but they'll move if you if you
throw yourself in with commitment
and any almost any wall will yield to
you at your best
second is
consider your identity
you'll behave consistent with your
identity so start to think about your
identity as your destination not your
past
third
make your decisions from your heart in
50 years i've never made a bad decision
from my heart
make your decisions from your heart and
not your head
nobody's coming to your rescue
no one's going to make that decision for
you no one's going to tell you it's time
no one's going to tell you you're ready
you're the only one who can give
yourself permission just you
but guess what you're the only one who
needs to give you permission too
and remember the journey will go through
the swamp when you're in the swamp give
me a call i'll help help you out of the
swamp but it's going to be normal and
fair is not fatal failure's not final
you control the clock
so i'll just end with a
story uh i had my stories about a my
executive coach named tom
so
i'm in the middle of the swamp
waist deep this is right after the reset
right here in the time of the recession
and i hired this coach named tom
so here's my introduction to tom i'm
going to reenact it here
i'm like hey tom i'm graham nice to meet
you he tom gives me this blank look
i'm like grant i always say this because
people graham's kind of weird obviously
graham like graham cracker
so i just maybe it's a nervous thing
this is tom tom says
graham
what if you suddenly realized
you were put on this earth to do
something special
so tom right
so good to meet you tom
that was literally our introduction
and then we talked for two years and
every single meeting we had at some
point sometimes multiple points
cram
what if you suddenly realized you were
put on this earth
to do something special
and this one time we were at in san
francisco we're at the deli and i'm like
there's like three people in front of us
and i'm like on my phone
tom's like
cram
what if you suddenly realized you were
put on this earth to do something
special so i'll ask all of you
what if you suddenly realized
suddenly realize you were put on this
earth to do something really special
think about that
and i want to draw a line for you and
you can do this tonight at home or you
can
when you have some time but there's a
line here
and you're on this side of the line
on this side of the line it's really
familiar
you've been here before you have these
thoughts from the past you have an
identity you're very comfortable in this
area right here
on this side of the line you probably
have some walls
you're in your head you're making
analytical decisions
but there's a line
and on and over here
is really what you want on the other
side it's what you really want
you know that and only you would know
that and your heart knows that
and over here
is you realizing
that the hero's journey
isn't just the best architecture of a
story
but it's the architecture of your life
it's the best story you could write with
this one life we got
and you're the hero of that journey
you get to be the hero of your story
and over here on this other side of this
line
is this call
to adventure
and you've been called to
if you really listen
and you really pay attention
there's a call over here
and finally on this side of the line
is going back to what michelangelo said
that you as you realizing
that you already have everything that
you need
and that you already are everything that
and that you're enough
that you're enough
well i finally realized
with tom i would go back and forth
thinking
is he
a little crazy or is he the messiah
sometimes in the same conversation
and i finally realized what he was
saying he wasn't saying
tom wasn't asking me
if
i was put on this earth to do something
special
he was asking me what would happen
if i realized that
so class of 2022 what would happen
if you realize that
and stepped over this line
thank you
thank you so much graham
thank you so much graeme for that
wonderful last lecture uh we're going to
move to q a uh so please raise your
hands if you have a question you would
like to ask
chris i'm a mic runner but i'll go first
is this on can you hear me yes um graham
thanks so much uh for that
i'm always struck in this conversation
and hearing about what you talk about in
class and talk about these limiting
beliefs which we talked about here too
do you ever feel the tension between
convincing yourself that you are enough
but also keeping that drive
to do something special
and how do you navigate that tension
no i i have it all the time i mean it's
uh it seeps in if you uh
it's not like it just goes away you have
the doubts and fears and limiting
beliefs all the time
and it's it's kind of what i said which
is i try to think about
what is it that i want you know what's
the what's the bigger why and
you know what if i just lean into that
and yeah definitely sometimes i have to
remind myself that i'm
that i'm enough it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't go away those voices
there's a there's a concept that you
know people have used calling our voices
inside our gremlin or saboteurs and i
remember thinking i was the only person
who had this voice that was like
pounding me with all this negative stuff
and then i realized oh my gosh
we all have that
so i think it doesn't it doesn't go away
but i think the awareness that it's
there is really the best thing you can
do to fight it
caroline has the next question
kevin
i also go by caroline uh graham thanks
appreciate the insights um you know on
one hand you talk about this sense of
urgency and actively chasing what it is
you think you're called to do
on this other hand there's this notion
of delayed gratification and spending
time either getting the credentials or
you know garnering the experiences
before you chase that thing
do you ever feel tension between those
two things and if so how do you
reconcile it yeah i don't know that
there's a conflict you know i think that
there's a false dichotomy in that kevin
um
what i mean is
when you're clear on where you want to
go you should 100 percent
accumulate things that are going to take
you there
and if that is knowledge if that's
experience you know accumulate things
that are going to take you where you
want to go
that's different than
this is where i want to go
i'm not ready so instead i'm going to
kind of start on this journey over here
and they're and they're very different
um so i think what you're describing is
yeah sure if you're if you're super
clear on your north star anything you
want to do to move toward that is
is going to be awesome
but just be
intellectually honest if you're really
doing that or if you're just kind of
moving
tangential to where you want to go
another question down here for orly
thanks so much graham um it was great to
hear from you today and i've loved being
in your class and i take many of the
things you've said to heart and they've
helped me i'm curious when you're like
genie goal or you're the thing you're
going after
um how do you balance that with the
people in your family and in your life
who are also going after their own
things when you have like interdependent
relationships
yeah it's a great question i think just
you know having a lot of communication
about what you're both going after and
then
you know what you're talking about
though i think is more of a tactic like
i i think you and ben should
support it
[Laughter]
support each other and trying to achieve
what the what you're both trying to
achieve and encourage each other and
there might be times when
you both have to
uh take on roles that you know that
you're gonna have to share that share
the duties but i i don't think that that
gets in the way of you both you know
clearly kind of walking toward what you
want to be going after
i think amanda the next question
hi graeme
uh let's imagine for a minute that the
angel has been revealed you've
self-actualized um
it's very nice lighting up here um i
want to understand how you maintain
humility and approachability when you
reach that that goal if if it is
attainable and to turn around and be
able to bring others up with you
you know i think i think one of the
things that um
i always thought was that
you know there's a great quote by miriam
williamson i'm not going to get it right
but she basically says
you know you giving yourself permission
gives other people permission you you
know you shining bright gives others
permission to shine bright and i think
there's i think there's so much truth in
that i mean i think about the people
that i admire the most like you know uh
whitney wolf heard came to our class
this year
and she's just herself she just like you
can just feel her energy and herself and
it
it and it doesn't from my mind doesn't
have anything to do with humility it
gave me permission to say wow this is
what someone who's really fired up about
what they want to do looks like
um so i in terms of you know i think
people that you perceive as arrogant are
probably
actually not doing that they're probably
trying to pretend and be something else
um the people that i know that i admire
the most they they're
you know they actually are pretty humble
and they're they're pretty happy with
who they are they're not trying to be
something different so i think sometimes
arrogance is
is almost the opposite of of being your
full your full self
joe
hey graham
you've come such a long way from being
that skinny kid striving to make it on
the wrestling team thank you and
my question
is um
you can just keep going
i mean
um my question is more you know when you
share that story of
friends coming to you you know they're
kind of all involved in tech they're
going with the bubble right
and
you're buying a label printing company
right
at that point how do you have conviction
to keep
doing what you're doing and not just
follow the herd and
what everyone else is doing yeah it's a
great question
there is
one person in my class who will remember
name remain nameless who follows every
herd you know it was hedge funds and in
the night it was dot com then it was
hedge funds and then you know i think
now he's doing like a crypto spac or
something
i'm actually not sure i'm exaggerating i
think that's icepitch
and
i think it's
i think for me at least i could see some
progress you know it was it wasn't all
bad like there would be moments where
i'd say i could kind of see how this
might work out and i i was having some
small little wins along the way which
was enough to keep me encouraged and the
other thing is i got really fortunate
that the very first
three or four people we hired at alpine
were just
unbelievable partners of mine and uh
you know they were in that they were in
the swamp with me
and uh there's a good expression i don't
know who said it which is like a problem
shared is a problem halved
and we were just in it together and um
and that you know there were days when i
would have a down day and i would need
to get dragged out and there were days
when they would and i would need to drag
them out so that was a huge part so i'd
say those two things is just having some
great people with me and then
and then just seeing a little bit of
progress along the way and also having
the conviction to not have to follow and
dive into the herd you know um i i
i literally didn't understand a lot of
it kind of
won't go off on my crypto tangent but i
don't understand i didn't understand a
lot of that and so i
yeah i i actually i actually didn't
wasn't like i'm smarter than everyone i
actually thought maybe i'm not as smart
as everyone but i'm but i stuck with
what i kind of understood
go down here mackenzie
thanks graham um i'm like right front
and center um
so kind of getting on the a little bit
the swamp point i think
looking back on
your career it's easier to say
just stick it out like stay in the swamp
you know you're struggling you know
obviously it worked out tremendously
how do you know
and we've heard a lot of stories from
people who've come to class of people
who have tried one thing it didn't work
out they left that on the side of the
road they went and did something
different or they pivoted their company
to something else like how do you know
when the time is right to just say or
what advice do you give to people to say
like hey like this is not working and
it's never going to and let me find
something and that's great question
there's a huge difference between
pivoting
and deciding you're done you know
there's a big difference i mean we
we pivoted
the whole time we're still pivoting i
mean i think that's really healthy like
that you know that to say hey this is
working really great let's do more of
that
and this isn't working let's do less of
that i mean i think that that's just
great
you know
leadership i mean that that's what
you're supposed to do
what's what's different is like
so often what i see is like
imagine you're running a marathon
i see people run 25 miles
and they don't know how close they are
and they turn around and run back
which is 25 miles back when they only
had to go one more season
they just finished the marathon
but uh so so i i think it's it's it's
not about
sticking with something that's not
working i think it's more just having
the confidence that you're going to
figure out the answer by you know with a
with a few pivots one thing i'll just as
an aside the thing the ones kind of
question that we've asked that has made
made us more successful maybe than any
other question is
what's working that we can do more of
most people focus on what's wrong and
what's not going right but it kind of
goes back to that angel in the marble
which is like there's actually some
things that we're really great at that
were
you know are true to us that are things
that make us
special let's like go all in on that so
for example at alpine
i would say i'm an average investor i
don't really have a ton of energy for
deals like that's not really what gets
me fired up but i'd say the thing that
gets me excited is people and talent and
we build a whole firm around that you
know we leaned into what we're good at
so i think giving yourself permission to
do that
uh kate
hi graham thank you so much for this
beautiful lecture
my question is about
reconciliation of this call to action
and follow your path and your passion
and your cause
and sacrifice
when sometimes things happen and things
change drastically and it can it's
another call to respond to some inner
values to
maybe some
traumatic experiences
in your family or something else how do
you reconcile
this
maybe time that you take away from your
path or
energy or anything else
on your journey yeah
well first off i'm
sorry if that's going what you're going
through right now so i'm i'm really
sorry to hear that
but uh what i'd say is what you're
describing actually is is your call
that's your louder call you know and
you're actually doing you're giving that
you're listening to that call and that's
that's that's the call that you should
be answering right now um
my call is i'm not ex i'm not saying to
anybody that you should be an
entrepreneur you should be a leader all
i'm saying is you should listen to
whatever
whatever's true for you whatever
whatever you in your heart you know what
the right thing is and it sounds like
for you right now that might be your
family so i think that's exactly what
you know you should be doing
and then when it's time you know you'll
you'll decide if you want to you know
listen to another call at that time but
it sounds like
you know the answer right now
thank you graham
you mentioned 99 of the people don't
figure out what they really want to do
you and others at this school and in our
lives have been supporting us
on this journey to figure out what we
want to do
going forward how can we continue to
help others in our life that are maybe
not in this room uh to figure that out
yeah
well the biggest thing you can do and
this is for all of you or people you
want to help is just make make space to
answer the to ask the questions
is you know you you have this cr like
all of you when you get a couple months
from now i know this is scary you're
going to actually be at work
and you might have back to back zoom
calls for 10 hours it's really easy just
to get swept up in that
and you need to make you need to make
space you know you need to put two hours
on the calendar and maybe you have a
coach or maybe you have a couple friends
you need to ask those questions you know
and it doesn't always come out of the
first session or the second one or the
third one it might might take weeks but
you have to make space to like listen
effectively and so the thing you could
give to your people you're trying to
help is that is
his space to ask these ask these
questions
i think our next question was back here
good afternoon graham thank you um
from someone who never made enough space
yet
very intrigued in your firm and yourself
and how you encourage people and you
focus on people and help them uncover
what they can be
what coaching do you give in terms of
balance between pursuing what you can be
identifying consuming and committing to
what you can be and the balance of
whatever everything else in life demands
right
do you see your team members struggling
with that balance and what advice do you
give
yeah
and just to be clear it's like the the
balance of
just how how much they're throwing
themselves into work and that they have
other stuff that goes away
you know
the
one way to think about this is um
and this is a framework
is that the amount of work that you have
is infinite
and you could fill your entire life with
it and it and you're never going to be
done
that's also kind of depressing but the
reason i'm bringing it up is
if you say you know i'm going to go to
my son's football game when i'm done
with my work or i'm going to make time
to exercise as soon as i'm done with
work or i'm going to go to my friend's
wedding when i'm done with work
like just realize you're never done with
work you know
there is no there's no such thing
for
someone like you who's you know driven
and wants to go
far
and so you have to put those other
things in first you know you have to say
you know i'm going to go to the son's
game or the wedding or whatever and then
the work's going to have to kind of work
around that
because if you don't put those things in
work will just consume
everything you know it and it it because
it's because there's never
you're never done there's there's so
much that you can do at all times so i
for some reason that that that framework
has helped me a lot not not ever say you
know not ever feel like oh i'm gonna at
some point be done because you're not
big melissa ratkinson
hi graham i'm melissa um i was lucky to
take your managerial skills class like
way back in the fall last year
and i love if you could re-share the
top mistakes you saw your classmates
make 20 years out because that was
something that really stayed with me
top mistakes my classmates made
i mean i i think i shared a
most of them in this talk um you know
which is
kind of get swept up say not that to the
two biggest most dangerous words
that you or my classmates ever say are
not now you know if you hear yourself
saying those words just be really really
careful
be afraid because not now is really
it's really fear kind of in another word
or in another
format and just be they're very it's
very dangerous because as i said earlier
you you become your environment
the people you're with become their
values become yours and so
mistake number one that i saw my
classmates make is just
putting it off and putting it off and
putting it off
and then and you know the other things
would be things i i talked about in the
talk which would be
um you know listening to your head not
your heart
and never really deciding what it is
you're excited about or what you want
those would be probably the biggest ones
i've seen
great we have time for one or two more
questions if there are any
uh we have kevin thank you
uh hi graham kevin here um so you're a
big fan of self development uh so i
wonder what do you think about like
improving on your weakness or
development area and you know
working on your strengths yeah
you know i'm a huge fan of working on
your strengths because that's what's
uniquely you
that's the thing you're that's where
your super power is is where your
strength
and you you know what what's interesting
is i always remember thinking well this
is my strength i'm sure it's everyone
else's strength and it's not
the thing that you love
uh naval ravicon always says what's the
thing that for you is play
that for everyone else feels like work
that's you know that's a good indication
of where you should be spending your
energy because you'll always
be better at that than anyone else
because you'll just do it for fun for me
that's teaching you know i mean
my wife can tell you that you know i'm
walking around in my house you know
working on lectures and giving this talk
that i just gave to my pillows in the
living room and
you know that because that's that's
that's play for me that's fun um
and
so i think i think leaning into your
things that you know really give you
energy is is your superpower
there will be weaknesses that could
completely take you out of the game
uh usually that has to do with
self-awareness
and you know how you're showing up
and some kind of hard edges you have
that's usually the weakness that takes
people out of the game
it's it's not usually intellect or
horsepower it's ability to get along
with people really
and
so that's that's one that you probably
need to you need to work on that enough
that you're not going to like shoot
yourself in the foot
you know playing to your strengths and
that you know that that's the one that
trips trips probably the most people up
that i've seen
our last question back here
hi graeme um i was incredibly grateful
to be one of your tas earlier this year
and i saw firsthand your commitment to
deni diversity equity and inclusion and
all of the things that you do to bring
other voices into the room or
other opinions into the room for people
that don't look like you sound like you
or have the same experience as you and
i'm thinking more about karen's question
of like how can we support other people
and whatnot who are not necessarily
involved in the same circles as us and i
was just wondering could you say a word
about what you do to learn or continue
to hear from people who don't look like
you sound like you and then what we
could do to incorporate that into how we
are showing up to board rooms meeting
rooms pitches whatever it might be so
it's really a question about learning
from diverse voices that's an awesome
question by the way thanks for the kind
words connor
i mean i'll tell you just an example
that that
we've learned over the years
and i'll use it as an example of
companies rather than talk in
generalities i'll use like a real
example
so when we go into a business we um
last year we
invested in we bought 127 businesses
last year
and when we go in most most often we are
actually putting in a new leadership
team because that's what the business
needs and we're very upfront about that
the first move we make is to
actually
enroll everyone in the company in where
we're going and we have this expression
that the answer's always in the room
we don't have the answer there's no top
down it is like literally enrolling
everybody in this in this conversation
and i remember when i i took over a
business when i was um
around 2010 and i became ceo
and
i did this i went on a listening tour
and i sat there with a yellow pad and a
pen and i went and met with
you know all the kind of
most of the leaders in the company
and a lot of the people that were on the
ground as well
and i sat down and the most common thing
that they ever said was
you know no one's ever asked me my
opinion before
and and the ideas were there like i
didn't have to be brilliant i just had
to like
give those voices oxygen and
not only did i get a better answer from
that but um
everybody felt like they contributed and
that they were enrolled in the solution
because you know they had been asked and
they'd been invited to that conversation
so you really just have to listen and
you don't have to be brilliant
the people the people that you're going
to lead the people that you're going to
be
involved with they will have the answer
and you just have to kind of
make sure you're giving giving their
voices some oxygen
you